[Musique]
je reviens me suis acharné pour une
chambre
y'a bras le chef des urgences qui vont
nous voir pourquoi tu as remarqué et
meego est trop de retard on a des
patients qui attendent depuis hier puis
je te ceux qui vont arriver je dois vous
nous aidiez aujourd'hui j'aimerais dire
oui si on va pas vous demander de faire
les choses folles où nous aider c'est
tout je comprends pas c'est quoi qui a
explosé de validation à cause du gel
surtout quand passion trafic entre
autres toi
[Musique]
la compassion écoutez pour le moment on
va maintenir les urgences les médecins
notamment
aucun jeu
[Applaudissements]
rabobank levé un peu trop
[Musique]
j'ai sauvé deux mais combatif et n'en
serait pas là
toujours su tourner pharmacienne
deux pas du tout jouer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
urgence m
[Musique]